- I always love your style
every time I see you.
And I'm not even a style person.
So this is reaching an audience
is what I'm saying.
- I appreciate that immensely.
You know, I had to pack
yesterday to come here.
- Are you good packer or
do you pack way too much?
- [Macklemore] It depends.
- Okay.
- There's moments where I'm like
I am tapped in to packing right now.
- I'm killing it.
- Like I have 12 outfits
for the next three days.
- Yeah. For the next three days?
- Yesterday I was like, I
need 17 pairs of underwear.
Two pairs of socks.
I was just out of it.
- I am so different from you.
I'm like, I have three pairs
of like legging type workout things
that I will not be working out in
but I'm gonna wear them every day.
And t-shirts and a jacket.
- Yeah. It's all you need.
- And like two shoes in case one breaks.
I'm like, I'm the worst.
I think its touring so much though.
I didn't wanna lug all
the (beep) everywhere.
Are you not supposed to-
I didn't wanna lug everything everywhere.
- Right
- It's a lot of stuff.
- I know. I'm keeping it daytime.
So, have y'all met before?
- No.
- Okay.
- Never.
- We just like to bring people together.
- I love that.
- Love it.
- Okay.
- Strangers on the couch.
- Strangers on a couch.
That was the name of our
initial thought for the show.
- [Macklemore] Yeah.
- Strangers on the couch.
Um, no. We both have kids.
We have two each, I
think, but you have three.
- I have three.
- [Kelly] Three kiddos.
- Wow, how's that?
- [Kelly] That's a lot.
You're outnumbered.
- We're playing zone defense, a lot.
And it's the best.
- Oh my God.
- And then it's the worst.
And then it goes back to the best.
And you just keep going.
Until you get through breakfast.
- That is actual parenting,
you should write a book.
That's exactly what it-
Oh my gosh.
- Cheeks
- So delicious.
Oh, I could smile for days.
So what do your kids think of your music?
Do you play your stuff?
Because sometimes I can't play mine.
'Cause cussing.
- Yeah.
No, my kids cuss like sailors.
They're dad raps.
It's just gonna happen.
It just happens.
- I tell mine they can't.
- There's things that I'm really good.
- Until they pay their bills.
- There you go.
- Yeah.
- That's smart.
- Do they think you're cool?
- Uh...
- My kids don't think I'm cool.
And I keep thinking to myself like,
you're gonna grow up one
day and think I'm so cool.
- That's what I think too.
- Like, I know cool people.
(Kelly laughing)
I hang out with cool people.
- [Kelly] How do you not get this?
- Yeah, "How do you not understand?"
- I think our kids don't, yeah.
They're around us all the time.
I don't know.
- Yeah, there's moments
of pivotal career times
in my life where like I'll look at my kids
and be like, "See what your dad just did?"
(Kelly laughing)
- "Do you appreciate this?"
- They don't care.
- "I'm incredible."
- "'Cause I just killed
it. Most of the time?
Not at all, but just
then it was a moment."
- "This one time, I'm amazing."
- [Macklemore] Yes.
(guests and audience laughing)
- You've been a really open
about relapsing, right?
So you, you relapsed during COVID.
- Yeah.
- Is that-
What do you think?
I mean, that was a hard
time for everybody.
Emotionally, physically, financially.
Like it kind of hit everybody.
Either all of that or, or you
know, a little bit of that.
What do you think hit you
to where you relapsed?
(Macklemore sighs)
My heart started beating when
you started talking about it.
It was an intense time.
You know, the life that I knew,
just like all of our
lives, was stripped away.
I'm used to a certain schedule
of touring, of being gone.
Of being home.
Of recovery and being able to go
to a physical 12-step meeting.
And that stopped during COVID
and eventually the Zooms weren't-
I was on Instagram while being on Zoom
and I'm just not really paying
attention to the meetings.
And eventually I thought,
and this is what happens
to me if I don't prioritize my recovery
if I don't put that first.
- Yeah.
- Then I will lose
everything in front of it.
- Yeah.
- That I'm putting in front of it.
And that's what happened.
And luckily it was only a couple weeks
but it caused a lot of pain.
You know, still.
I still feel that pain
and it's been two and a half years
I'm still working of getting back trust.
But I think that it gave me a
reprieve of a reminder, again.
A slap in the face.
Not a delicate reminder, but
a slap in the face reminder,
this is your life.
You get one of these.
What are you going to do
with your precious time on this earth?
Do you want to be secretive?
Do you want to be hiding?
Do you want to be in the shadows
or do you want to live your
life to the fullest potential?
Get back on it.
And be honest.
(audience clapping)
- I think the most important thing
that you just said for
me is those meetings.
That being present and
being held accountable
and like on a, you know-
- Community.
- Weekly thing, and
like having a community.
- Community, yes
- Having that support is so important.
And that's everybody-
I mean, not everybody,
but I know a lot of people relapsed
in their own addictions,
their own things they had going on in life
because they weren't, they
didn't have any support.
We realized how fragile
we are without community,
without our village.
Like, without our people that understand
and even just showing up
and having a regular routine of something.
Like, that's hard.
I think we all realize
that in our own lives.
- Right.
- So before the break,
we were talking about
your relapse during COVID.
So how do you think that
impacted or affected your album?
- I think that pain is a
catalyst for great art.
I don't want to inflict the pain
on myself anymore to make art.
You know, it's not like
I need to self sabotage
in order to create.
But I think that it created
some darker, more honest,
vulnerable moments on the album.
And I think that that's important.
Again, a relapse is not, you know,
it's not why I relapsed
or any sort of part of the process,
but it does create that vulnerability.
So I think that that's probably the effect
that it had on the album
was just real pain.
- Yeah.
Which that's why, I don't
know like why you both got
into the art we're in, but
like, that's my outlet.
Like it became my outlet when I was a kid.
Like, I started writing
and it was like more poetry
before I like started singing or whatever.
But that was like, that's how I like-
People are always like, "Oh man, why-"
'Cause sometimes people are
always like and I say this too,
"I write better when I'm
more in a sad or hard place."
- Right.
- Like, it's harder.
Like, 'cause I'm not really
writing to get the happy out.
I like to keep the happy in.
- Yeah.
- It's like I'm trying to-
Did you get into it maybe for an outlet?
Was it your outlet?
- Absolutely.
It still is my outlet.
- Me too.
- It still is my therapist.
On top of my therapist, but-
- Me too!
- I also think that most
artists have like an enormous
amount of empathy and
no one ever teaches us
how to deal with that empathy.
- Yes.
- Nobody teaches us that
it doesn't need to pierce-
- It's overwhelming.
- Yeah.
- No one teaches us how
to not be overwhelmed
by the hardships we see
in life or face in life.
So I think that's a reason
why a lot of artists self-medicate.
- [Macklemore] Yes.
- 'Cause nobody's ever taught them
how to protect themselves while creating.
And while feeling.
- Yeah.
Well, because the process of creation
is to strip away these layers, right?
We're peeling away
these layers constantly.
Let me get closer to the heart.
Let me try to get inside.
And once we do that, then
we become more vulnerable.
We're like susceptible
to feeling that empathy
or that compassion or that
pain or whatever it is.
And, yeah, we're not taught the tools.
- Yeah. Not at all.
I hear that you found
a new passion though.
Golf?
- [Macklemore] Yes.
- You're a golfer.
- Yes.
- I feel like you probably
look fabulous on a golf course.
- [Macklemore] You know what?
- What do you wear on a golfer course?
- Kelly, I'm gonna be honest
- Because it's not great attire.
- No, no, no, but it is now.
- It is now?
Oh, 'cause you have your own line.
- I started my own golf clothing company.
- That's so smart
- 'Cause I was going into these stores.
(audience clapping)
- It's like very basic and boring.
- It's very basic.
- Yeah.
- Golfers, they love khaki.
Khakis!
It's just khakis.
And I love khaki. Okay?
- But we're not going
to work in a cubicle.
- No, it's the same.
It was the same outfit.
And I'm like, you know what,
I've always been inspired
by old golf clothing
from like the seventies
and the eighties.
- The knickers.
- Yeah, the knickers.
Tthe tartans. The plaids.
All of that was always so cool
to me as I grew up thrifting.
And so I would have on
these old golf outfits.
So, you know, fast forward a couple years.
Here we are starting to
play the game of golf.
And I'm like, you know what?
I've loved this.
This is a perfect lane for
me to do something different.
- Oh, wait.
- What's happening?
- What is this number?
- And I brought-
- I'm getting this.
- Yes.
- I brought, both of you.
Both of you.
- This is cute. This is you.
- That is so cute.
- I feel like this is you.
What is this?
- I want this one for you.
'Cause it goes with your colors.
- This is a lavender.
Lavender tracksuit, okay.
- Wait, can we trade?
- I don't know if lavender's back,
but if it's not, we're bringing it back.
Okay?
- Oh my god.
I love the colors.
Look at her dressing,
right now. (laughing)
- This is amazing.
- With a skirt.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my god. I love this.
- Yes!
- I am doing it. I'm doing it live.
- Doing it.
- Doing it live.
- I'm doing it live.
- We doing it live.
- We doin' it live.
(crowd cheering )
- Oh God.
- It's a living post.
- Oh my God, Oh my God
- Get my heel, get my heel.
You look incredible, right now.
I love what's happening right now.
- Nobody look. Everybody close your eyes.
Okay.
- Can I look?
- Oh my god.
- Oh my God.
(crowd cheering)
- Look at this.
Look at this.
(crowd cheering)
(fun upbeat music)
- [Kelly] You've got to model.
Don't worry about it.
(crowd cheering)
- Yes. Yes.
- You know what's amazing
about you is you are that hot
that you're actually pulling
off all of it right now.
- You're amazing.
- Oh my gosh.
Macklemore's new album is called Ben.
You guys, it's great.
Check it out.
It drops March 3rd.